[Music]
this was my favorite moment from dragon
ball
super and so apart from the glaringly
obvious on the surface
i wanted to figure out why this scene
works so well and why that music
fits so perfectly throughout my years
covering dragon ball and countless hours
online discussing it
one vital component to its worldwide
success oftentimes failed to receive the
appreciation it deserved and trust me
i'm one of those people too because i
totally failed to fully appreciate and
observe it
and that aspect i'm talking about is
music
more specifically the soundtrack now i
know what you're thinking
mark i've grown up with the show i've
spent so much time listening to the
music i've heard all the songs and yeah
okay i get it i can sing all the lyrics
to chala head challah too
you're not special but now after taking
a closer look the staggering amount of
detail and planning that goes into so
many films tv shows and musicals is
honestly
jaw-dropping and despite the fact i've
spent tons of time committed to the
narrative side of dragon ball
as it happens i've yet to tip the
iceberg in the music department
today i will be exploring dragon ball
super's music and why
it's more important than you think
[Music]
dragon ball super broly was critically
acclaimed across the board from an
animation standpoint but
also from a musical all right that track
might have been a little more
experimental and divisive but my point
is dragon ball super broly soundtrack
was viewed as
leaps and bounds ahead of dragon ball
supers particularly its earlier stuff
and that's with good reason tracks like
omen of victory and
turning the tables in dragon ball super
are not only tracks that more often than
not were poorly placed within the anime
by the directors but they were also
clearly designed to project a more
kid-friendly vibe within the story
and that's important to understand but
i'll get into that a little later
because
some people seem to have this idea that
sumitomo the composer who was enlisted
to create the music for one of the
biggest
intellectual properties on the planet in
dragon ball suddenly started to get good
at creating music
halfway through his time on the series
which just flat out isn't true but
anyway so
dragon ball super's musical score was
heavily criticized in the earlier arcs
due to its evidently poor implementation
lobbing the blame largely on the
individual creating it until eventually
the standard became
evidently elevated now gee where have i
heard that before
something starting off bad in dragon
ball super but slowly getting better
over the course of the series only to
crescendo at the broly movie
oh yeah it's the animation for years now
i
as well as countless others have spoken
at length about the hardships the
animation department suffered during the
production of super
and back in the distant past of 2015
talk on the mainstream level regarding
animation and the development of which
within the industry was criminally low
so it was an important conversation to
have and i'm glad we had it
but music way too often gets left out of
that conversation or forgotten entirely
despite it being a casualty of super's
ridiculous production schedule also
you heard me sumitomo did not have
enough time to create a soundtrack for
dragon ball super
or at least not enough time to create
the soundtrack that he wanted
and there's proof of this if you look at
his work before he started working on
kai
or super the tracks that he was making
sounded remarkably similar to what he
ended up making towards the end of the
super series and in broly i mean
if you really think about it there's
even more working against the musical
score of dragon ball super because
sumitomo doesn't even get to place the
music himself
that goes to the directors of individual
episodes
who think that this is an appropriate
track to play while vegeta is charging
his galaga
this is not the song you use when your
protagonist is up against a literal wall
and struggling against difficult odds
and there's literally no excuse for this
because a much more appropriate track
was already available for that scene
and i know this because they used that
very intense track
in episode 6 when goten and trunks were
having a
water gun fight
the reason why this bothers me so much
isn't just because the atmosphere or
vibe
portrayed through the music doesn't
match what's on screen but also because
if done well which as we've seen with
the broly movie can be the case
if a score is given enough time to be
developed they can tell a story using
that music too
and this is where i introduce many of
you to a musical technique used in
stories called
johaku the light motif a light motif is
defined as
an uncomplicated musical phrase or theme
that represents a person
place or idea within the story the idea
behind the implementation of light
motifs within modern media by and large
is to create a correlation between
recurring concrete aspects of a story
and the soundtrack this in turn helps
people identify what score represents
what aspect of the film as well as help
people better understand the story at
large in some cases
think of it as the music helping you to
better understand the story and this
might sound horribly complicated but
i assure you it's not take this for
example in the original dragon ball
story the musical arrangement
that accompanies the visuals has become
widely known as the kikuchi score
named after the man himself who composed
it mr score i'm kidding it's
kikuchi this is an example of a score
that was given the appropriate time to
prepare interesting melodies
for and in the case of this example
light motifs
[Music]
[Applause]
this is king piccolo's theme as most of
you might be familiar with it
if you're not listen up because here it
is piccolo's most significant section of
dragon ball story from a narrative point
of view can be seen from the king
piccolo saga through to
the saiyan saga
[Applause]
as soon as king piccolo appears as an
old namekian in the king piccolo saga
kikuchi lays the groundwork for his
light motif
this sounds significantly different to
the one i showed you before
though the feeling is still sort of
there it gets across the evil intent but
it's slow it feels like it's building up
to that melody but it just can't quite
do it
communicating to us that he's not king
piccolo in this form
he's not complete and this is perfectly
representative of the plot too
at this point in the story piccolo is
spending all of his resources and
efforts to become
young and powerful again and once he
does we finally hear it
his light motif
as soon as he assumes this form the true
king piccolo light motif plays
there's significantly higher notes it's
faster and the melody line finishes in a
really satisfying way
and in the same way the melody is fully
realized so too is king piccolo
but this is where it gets interesting
piccolo juniors
is different again
once again keeping the same melody line
it employs a much faster and playful
tone
getting across that there's a
fundamental element to this character
that is the same but that he is much
younger again
and most importantly it's his own person
and as the show progresses so too did
the theme until the most pivotal moment
in piccolo's life
his time spent with gohan
even without the context of the scene if
someone just played the music for you
while you would recognize it as
piccolo's light motif
it communicates a much softer heartfelt
approach and musically this is very
important for the series
the music in this instance isn't just
dressing for the scene to match the tone
it communicates part of the story
piccolo's internal struggle and change
to the side of good
even without the context of this scene
if someone just played this music for
you while you would recognize it as
piccolo's light motif it communicates a
much softer
heartfelt approach standing in harsh
contrast with piccolo jr's fast and
pitchy rendition from earlier in the
series
this communicates that piccolo is
changing or in this case
has changed and that's the strength of
the light motif it's a piece of music
that represents something concrete
within the story
and helps to communicate story elements
to the audience as a result
if you weren't aware of this then
welcome i hope you enjoy stories much
more now but the point that i'm trying
to make here is
musical scores serve much more of a
purpose in a scene than just setting the
mood
they can as made evident by what i just
demonstrated above help you better
understand what's going on in a scene
in the case of piccolo it was his
internal struggle to the site of good
but this technique isn't just
limited to the kukuti score of dragon
ball either the same can be observed
with the faulconer score of dragon ball
z from the late 90s too
an easy example can be seen with the
track gohan angers
initially a variation on a motif
associated with gohan early on in the
series this one really takes on a life
of its own
in this one pivotal scene in the series
as gohan transforms
in front of cell to win the day however
this track also is used elsewhere in the
series during gohan's mystic
transformation with boo fight you
no i wanna kill you throughout the buu
saga were introduced and listened to
various other pieces of music for
characters such as the supreme kai or
even instances where that realm he comes
from
is of focus predominantly this new
aspect to the series in the kais and the
other world
are represented with a much more synthy
sound rather than the traditional
instrumentation we've come to expect
from faulkner and this is largely there
to create a distinction musically
between new inclusions to the story
and the main cast this adds a fresh
atmosphere to the arc but it also added
something wonderful to gohan's light
motif because the mystic
form had been given to him by the old
kai it is in part associated with that
aspect of the series now and with this
while the theme of gohan
angers plays it is distinct from the
cell saga's incarnation of the track
it has both ties to gohan's character
and the realm of the kais
okay so that's light motifs and trust me
there's way more to this there's like
diegetic and non-diegetic music in film
and why certain instrumentation sounds
good to you because of where you grew up
and heck i'll hold my hand up there's
still a ridiculous amount of stuff that
i still don't understand because
i really only started reading about it a
month or so ago but there's still one
aspect i need to share with you all that
demonstrates how music makes you feel
emotion that honestly took me by
surprise
and that's contrast if i were to
approach a person on the street and ask
them what sort of music would you put
with a sad scene to make it feel more
sad apart from responding with get away
from me you weirdo what do you think the
most popular answer among this survey
would be
personally i would have said sad music
right i mean these are scenes that make
you cry after all but
as it happens this actually isn't true
at all with a sad scene if you want to
get the most emotion out of a viewer
uplifting music usually works best think
about it for a sec for me the scene that
makes me cry a little more than i'm
comfortable to share with you all online
is the last episode of dragon ball gt
for those of you that aren't familiar
with it the episode is comprised of a
series of goodbyes goku shares with a
number of his friends from vegeta to
piccolo to krillin but
usually during this section i'm able to
keep it together where i lose it however
is
right in the last scene as goku walks
away through the grounds of the world
martial arts tournament
effectively saying goodbye to all of us
now fans of gt and this episode will be
able to tell you what theme plays during
this scene
and it's the opening theme song dan dan
kokuro now those of you that have seen
my review of this series you'll know
that i'm not the biggest fan of gt
no and neither do i because this is the
worst episode of dragon ball i've ever
seen
despite this however i always enjoyed
the gt theme song
even in my review series i mentioned how
i love the opening because it really
captures that sense of grand adventure
which dragon ball always represented for
me and throughout the series of gt
whenever a pivotal moment came about
you best believe we'd be hearing this
theme song in one form or another
through various remixes and reimaginings
and instead of many other tranquil or
sad tracks that they could have chosen
from throughout the series they decided
to end it
with dan dan and the reason being is
contrast the song that represents
adventure and fun
now accompanies the scene that
represents goku's adventure
ending and the narrator says as much
this is where the story of dragon ball
ends so on top of this track already
acting as a light motif for adventure
and positivity in the series
it can also be used as a mechanism to
stand in direct contrast to a quieter
and somewhat sad moment
creating a stark comparison in her mind
which breeds emotion
but let's get back to super for now
[Music]
a good friend of mine t hallums on
twitter and youtube in addition to
helping me put together the information
for this video
also enjoys fixing the musical choices
in the early scenes of super check them
out it's honestly amazing what changing
the music in his scene to something
appropriate can do to elevate it but
something you might notice however on
that channel
is stop right there
apart from one or two strays the vast
majority of his edited scenes cover
only material prior to episode 46 and
that's because around this time similar
to the animation of the series
the quality started to improve this is
also when sumitomo made one of the most
memorable musical tracks
in the entire series
[Music]
goku black is one of the most easily
recognizable and memorable characters to
come out of dragon ball super
and sumitomo helped him by giving him an
amazingly nefarious villain theme that
crawls inside your brain and stays there
it's catchy and it's perfect for the
character and this arc also has another
theme i adore too
zamasu's theme while significantly more
understated than his more goku-centric
counterpart
it's still catchy and encompasses his
character perfectly but one aspect of
this arc i thought they didn't
capitalize on from a musical standpoint
was in the fusion of the two characters
and so i thought it would be fun to
commission my friend pokeymixer92 on
youtube and twitter
to create for me a perfect marriage of
the two respective themes to create
one perfect fused zamasu theme
implementing elements from both
to create something new and needless to
say he did just that
[Music]
[Music]
i thought that was sick and because that
one turned out so well i asked him to
make me one more
i thought that since few zamasu loses
his mind becomes corrupted physically
later on in the story his theme should
reflect that insanity too
and this is what pokemixer came up with
[Applause]
[Music]
these tracks were really fun to workshop
and if you'd like to see these full
clips and scenes with the music unedited
i will upload them onto my twitter
at totally not mark alright enough
fooling around now that we've got
context and understanding regarding some
basic fundamentals of music literacy
let's take a closer look at dragon ball
super once again
understanding the purpose music plays in
storytelling now we can with great
understanding appreciate how utterly
ridiculous this scene is
the music doesn't communicate anything
other than that the directors and staff
involved were really scrambling to at
all costs put an episode together on
time
however when it came to this scene it
absolutely
knocked it out of the park for me and so
using everything we've learned today
let's see if we can on some level
understand why i loved it so much
the track is distinctly dragon ball
super none of the other series discus
sound
anything like it which helps the story
being told have its own identity
but that's just superficial surface
dressing those of you that have been
paying attention will also notice that
this track is in
of itself a light motif but what does it
represent and where did it come from the
track backing up this scene you might
recognize is a remix of the main theme
of the universe survival arc
limit break x survivor listen carefully
[Music]
in the same way dragon ball gt
implemented its own theme in pivotal
moments to hearken back to something
familiar
so too does this track work in that way
well the story being told in this arc is
that of universe 7 needing to band
together with unlikely comrades to
defend their own universe from erasure
in a multiverse team-oriented battle
to end all battles and this variation of
the theme is played not just here but in
a few other instances to reinforce the
fact that this track
represents trust and teamwork the first
obvious one comes in episode 109 as goku
begins calling on his team to lend him
their energy for one of his signature
finishing moves
the spirit bomb because this is one of
the first notable inclusions of this
track in the series this particular
piece of music has become widely known
as the genki dhamma theme on youtube but
it
is in fact a light motif derived from
the original op that not only has
nothing to do with this scene
specifically but also has nothing to do
necessarily with spirit bombs for
example another instance that this track
makes an appearance for is during the
closing moments of one of my favorite
scenes concerning piccolo and gohan in
the series
downed and trying to rally themselves
piccolo looks on as gohan has his back
and together they finally overpower the
team of universe 6's namekians thanks to
their combined efforts these scenes with
the spirit bomb
and the team up of gohan and piccolo
gave me chills
but they didn't really invoke the same
sort of visceral reaction or emotion
that the scene in the final episode did
and that is primarily due to contrast i
spoke about this briefly during my
breakdown of this scene in my review of
the ark
but it's worth repeating for the sake of
this point now now
the entire crux of this scene leans
heavily on the story being told by
frieza in this arc
and this scene this conversation with
goku acts as its climax
throughout the tournament he has really
been working on his own
unable to fight alongside others
oftentimes only contributing to the
action in the latter stages by
blindsiding the antagonists before
ultimately being kicked to the sidelines
to lick his wounds and by the time the
final battle comes around he's made it
known that he clearly struggles to work
alongside others
reinforced by the dialogue he screams
towards 17 who is
only trying to keep him alive he doesn't
want to rely on anyone because
he can't trust anything anyone says in
his mind he'd betray them so
why would they not do the same to him
this way of thinking is what makes
sense to frieza made obvious by his
responses to seventeen's restricted but
sincere words aimed towards him
in episode one three one
despite looking down on this sort of
behavior as a weakness the battle
suddenly takes a turn for the worst
jiren now fueled by a new motivation
finds hidden reserves of strength
forcing frieza to have to hide behind
the defenses of his ally
17. kicking and screaming frieza is
forced to shed his gaudy golden exterior
and is forced to relinquish his
dwindling energy reserves
to seventeen shields to defend them both
but just like frieza feared and
suspected
this trust isn't enough the shield is
seconds from breaking and it's looking
like trust in teamwork is nothing in the
face of
absolute power
the ethereal music from this track cuts
through the air and replaces all the
despair we felt leading up to this
with hope as frieza finally has a
conversation about trust with goku it's
the best conversation in the entire
series in my opinion and this track
reinforces every single aspect of this
scene
made all the more powerful because as
viewers we are so invested in the
conclusion to this upcoming conflict
we've no idea who's going to win and in
a way we too
have to put our trust in this unlikely
team it's a wonderfully crafted piece of
music that not only uplifts this scene
but creates a gorgeous contrast with
the most unlikely teammates of goku and
frieza and implements a reliable light
motif we've made a connection with
during the tournament and that is why
this scene is my favorite in the series
and if you're still not convinced that
this scene or this arc is about teamwork
or trust
just check out jiren's final words when
he's defeated at the tournament of power
so this is trust universe 7's power
over my years on this channel i've
spoken at length about the animation
troubles and woes of dragon ball super
as well as the narrative quality and
shortcomings of the series at length as
have
countless others across youtube and the
internet at large
the topic has become so ubiquitous that
it's honestly difficult to find an
instance on twitter where someone brings
up the animation quality of the series
without someone at least mentioning the
reasons behind it once in the underlying
comments
and this is a great thing for an
audience to be so educated about a
particular topic is commendable and
it's honestly one of the best things
about living in the modern age to me
when someone says that dragon ball
super's animation was terrible
there's plenty of people right there to
provide the facts but this is no
different to the music of the series
when someone says that sumitomo is a
terrible composer there are
comparatively fewer to jump to the
defense of this fantastic artist that
too struggled against the clock
as well as other heavy factors it's easy
to notice great animation when we see it
it's flashy and it's bombastic but
rarely can we say the same about music
if a musical score is doing its job
oftentimes we don't even notice it as it
seamlessly integrates itself into our
subconscious in an effort
to tell a compelling story and so as
viewers and
fans it's our responsibility to
recognize when it's in trouble and to
appreciate when they show themselves
the pockets of hidden genius in dragon
ball's music
i want to give a special thanks to t
hans who helped me with so many of the
specifics in this video without him this
wouldn't have happened
special thanks also goes out to
pokemixer92 for creating some of these
custom themes
in the video like the few zamasu theme
and the corrupted few zamasu themes
check both t hallums and pokemixer out
on youtube and twitter
also if you found this particular dive
into musical score theory interesting
i couldn't recommend a channel on
youtube called sideways
more he specializes in music video
essays goes into way more detail than i
ever could
and i honestly think he makes some of
the best video essays on the platform
period
check him out if you haven't already but
as for me next week
i begin a new adventure through the
crazy world of jojo's bizarre adventure
and i can't wait to share it with you
all this one will be much
much shorter than the one piece series
and i hope you all can join me for the
ride to see what all the hype is about
and to make things a little bit more
interesting the author of jojo's bizarre
adventure has actually made
a how to write book discussing his
approach to narrative theory
so let's see how the early work stands
up against his own standards and let's
see if this bizarre adventure will be a
great one
i'll see you all there but until then
i've been totally not mark
and thank you so much for watching